when Nancy Pelosi made that statement we
have to pass the bill so that you can
find out what is in it that was the
clincher I said I've got to write a book
to let the people know hi I'm Ted
bellacor with reason TV and today i'll
be speaking with Sally pipes pipes is
president and CEO of the Pacific
research institute an author of most
recently the truth about Obamacare what
they don't want you to know about our
new health care law why did you write
this book well a Canadian and I grew up
under government run healthcare and so
looking at what the president wanted to
do to the American healthcare system
really made me think I've got to focus
on this and let the American people know
what Obamacare means to what extent is
it fair to compare Obamacare to what
Canada has Obamacare right now is
slightly different than the Canadian
healthcare system the Medicare system
but I believe that the president is
speaker Pelosi and Senate Majority
Leader Harry Reid want to take us down
the path to a single-payer
government-run medicare-for-all system
and this is just Obamacare the 2500 page
act is just sort of a stepping stone to
that because it's not going to work and
the plan on proposing will cost around
nine hundred billion dollars over ten
years the plan will not add to our
deficit the middle class will realize
greater security not higher taxes and if
we are able to slow the growth of health
care costs by just one-tenth of one
percent each year one-tenth of one
percent it will actually reduce the
deficit by four trillion dollars over
the long term well of course none of
these things are going to happen under
the Affordable Care Act it's probably
going to cost about 2.5 trillion dollars
over ten years many economists have said
this and I think it's in the it's
definitely true the the cost curve is
not going to bend down you know the
president said over and over again still
says it that the average premium for the
average family will go down by twenty
five hundred dollars and the CBO said it
will go up by 21 hundred dollars and we
know that to be the case so that's an
outright lie and as to universal
coverage the congressional budget
office's also said that by 2019
23 million Americans will still be
uninsured so we're throwing out the
world's finest healthcare system that
could have you know we could have made
some improvements and we would continue
to have the world's finest but now we
are on this path to a single-payer
system and taxes are going to go up for
all Americans not just wealthy Americans
everyone is going to face tax increases
the deficits are going to increase and
we are going to have our care rationed
and will be rationed or denied by
government we have to be very very
careful about what this means for the
long-term care of Americans because we
won't have access to the latest drugs
and treatments I noticed that one of the
the latest drugs you mentioned was
Rituxan we interviewed a fellow whose
life was saved thanks to this wonder
drug a cancer drug you point out that in
Canada it's available in some provinces
correct so that is perhaps even evidence
of you know there's a pretty specific
example of availability US vs canada
right well in 2003 my uncle had been
diagnosed with non-hodgkins lymphoma and
my cousins a doctor in Vancouver and I I
said well what about Rituxan for Uncle
Fred and he said well he knew the head
of the cancer agency in BC and he'd
never heard the head had never heard of
Rituxan and he got back to my cousin two
weeks later and said well you know it's
not available here but if you want to
take your dad to Seattle Washington to
the Fred Hutchinson clinic please you
know go ahead but at that point my uncle
was too old and and really ill because
he is carried never they had not done
the test to find out that he had NHL so
you know you know that's an example and
then a woman in Toronto read my book and
said well I can't get Rituxan in Ontario
and I was able to tell her that it was
available in Alberta it's probably
available now in some other provinces
but government controls costs in Canada
by not allowing access for the provinces
to some of these you know high-end
treatments because they determine
they're too expensive and that's I think
what's going to happen under Don Berwick
and this whole new comparative
effectiveness center under under
Obamacare the government is going to say
that you know the value of your life is
forty nine thousand a year that the cost
of avastin is
a forty fifty thousand a year therefore
it may be medically effective for you
but it's not cost-effective so it'll be
denied and that's how governments keep
costs under control and but who does it
hurt it hurts patients the supporters of
Obama care I believe we're at a
rhetorical advantage on many different
levels unless you say our current system
is a complete and total and utter mess
you are a defender of the status quo
right and so but for some reason because
of the media and what politicians
liberal politicians have been telling
people they be the American people have
become it to some extent to believe that
healthcare is a right it's not the same
as you know whether you mean should the
government you know provide our housing
should they provide you know our
vacations I mean so but people began to
think that healthcare is a right and in
fact you know the American people are
spending less per year on their health
care than they are on you know travel
and entertainment but but they begin to
think that's all right for me to you
know take spend my own money to go to to
Paris on a vacation or go to
Indianapolis or whatever but but they
seem to think it's not right for them to
have to pay for their health care and
that is unfortunately a real mistake
health care is not a right we have the
right to go and get health care but we
don't have a right for it to be provided
for us and so I mean you know if you get
a starbucks coffee twice a day and that
cost you six dollars you don't think
that's a problem but you know you don't
want to spend you know 120 hundred and
thirty dollars to go to the doctor I'm
to find out you know why you have you
know sore throat or you know a pain in
your stomach or whatever so people have
become very you know sort of overtaken
by the fact that people now think health
care is an entitlement that the
government should provide and you know
we're spending 17.3 percent of our gross
domestic product on health care and
people said well it's way too much
Canada spends 10 we yes Canada spends 10
because the government says that's what
we can afford and then you get those
long waiting lists denied care and lack
of access to the latest technology you
know I'm part of the baby boom
generation you know we're all going to
when we retire there's gonna be a whole
flood of new people you know that are
going to have to go on Medicare and we
know it's you know it's being cut by
five hundred twenty nine billion over
ten years we're going to have a hard
time finding doctors
and having access to the best care but
you know we need to voucherize Medicare
we need to voucherize Medicaid there's a
whole bunch of things that can be done
to empower doctors and patients and keep
our health care system alive but it's
not going to happen it's going to be
destroyed under this takeover of our
system since Obamacare has already
passed is it too late for us what can we
do now I favor repeal and replace now if
the Republicans take over the house this
fall and if they even take the Senate
that is not going to be enough for
repeal and replace that the Republicans
would have to take the presidential
office in 2012 and Congress and then
early in 2013 they would have to work
very hard on repeal and replace but it
also means having a strong leader who
can sort of heard all these cats so that
they focus on repeal and replace and
then we can build with a health care
system which I talked about in my book
empowering doctors and patients changing
the tax code reducing getting States to
reduce their mandates allowing people to
buy insurance across state lines all of
these things but if they don't you know
as Milton Friedman used to always say to
me Sally tell me a government program
that has ever been eliminated you know
the angora mohair subsidy program very
few are ever you know eliminated so
we've got to get on this right away and
but it will take a lot of willpower and
a strong leader to make it happen